mi chiamo raffaele ma io ho vissuto
cinque anni senza utilizzare soldi ho
fatto
ho accettato e soldi nello spendere
soldi per creare più coscienza che tutti
noi abbiamo una responsabilità in questa
terra e che vivere e cambio che vogliamo
vedere nel mondo come ha detto gandhi
non solo è una possibilità ma è nostra
responsabilità in questi cinque anni o
successo tanto ma è spreco del cibo
spreco di risorse
la distruzione della foresta
no ha sminuito ma solo aumentato quindi
in questi anni volevo creare qualcosa
che cambia questo ma no no riuscito a
fare tanto perché il mondo è molto
grande ma anche viviamo oggi e non tempo
di crisi anche abbiamo tanti problemi
personali
c'è problemi e in questo grande mondo
secondo me siamo fortunati di vivere in
questi tempi perché oggi cambiare mondo
è più bello e più facile che mai e anche
non potevo cambiare mondo intero in
questi cinque anni ho smesso e lo
sciopero dei soldi perché perso la
fiducia fiducia e la umanità come
diventato troppo depressivo le tante
cose negative kahn che succedano
anzi al contrario e visti tanti belli
progetti centinaio iniziative in tutto
il mondo e persone che cambiano che
creano cose che aiutano a un mondo
migliore un mondo dove tu teano è
sufficiente a un cibo da mangiare e dove
tutti si possano sviluppare e aiutare
agli altri oggi viviamo in un tempo dove
ci sono ancora tanti problemi ma
comunque anche se abbiamo questi
problemi il nostro mondo c'è tante cose
più che ci un ano cose positive pensieri
i sogni che c'è un anno come umanità che
c'è
dividano e che l'associazione e nel
mondo è diverso per ogni persona ma
secondo me le ho più importante è che
ascoltiamo la nostra cuore e pensiamo
che possiamo fare noi e noi aspettiamo
agli altri che possano fare altri ma che
possa fare io
e quando stavo studiando en olanda 7
anni fa insieme con i miei due amici a
nicola dell'italia e benjamin della
francia e abbiamo scoperto che nel mondo
oggi si spreca 50 per cento del cibo enò
europa 30 per cento del cibo e del mondo
l'europa ancora di più perché a stesso
momento 70 per cento di tutta la
superficie della agricoltura e nel mondo
se usa esclusivamente per le animali e a
stessi momento ogni giorno 800 milioni
di persone vanno a letto con fame e si
svegliano con fame
e anche se solo è anche 14 miliardi di
persone potevano alimentare e non lo
facciamo perché non lo facciamo perché
c'è spreco perché diamo tanto cibo agli
animali invece di aiutare le altre
persone che non hanno sufficiente e per
me ho capito che devo svegliarmi e
cambiare qualcosa e con chi si può
cambiare il mondo con se stesso e lo più
facile in squadra con degli altri
quindi io ho deciso di andare al messico
ma no per caso ma due persone anno
amici mi hanno fatto la invita azione
alla sul matrimonio e marzo 2010 e
pensavo magari quello e comune nvidia
zione del destino e quindi insieme con i
miei due amici abbiamo pensavo pensato
ma con possiamo andare al messico
perché solo il volo a messico e tornare
spreca brucia tanto co2 come una persona
deve usare o produrre in due anni quindi
uno stato per noi una possibilità è
andare line aereo e volevano fare
qualcosa diverso per ogni problema c'è
perlomeno una soluzione e avevamo
cercato come possiamo andare là volare
non possiamo quindi abbiamo fatto un
viaggio cominciato un viaggio in
autostop da olanda a messico senza soldi
e con un piccolo zaino
volevamo scoprire la bellezza della
umanità e scoprire che bello sono alla
gente e che tanto problemi ce e tanto
soluzione ci sono fuori che dobbiamo
condividere
siamo partiti in gennaio 2010 per oropa
marocco le isole canarie e la stavamo
cercando per tre settimane una barca
verso altro lato dell'atlantico mano
abbiamo trovato nessun una barca che ci
voleva prendere e un giorno abbiamo
cercato anche in i bidoni la cibo
certamente ma anche altre cose
abbiamo trovato una bandiera di messico
quello ci ha dato nuova energia il
prossimo giorno siamo andati molto
cariche al porto e abbiamo trovate sugli
italiani che volevano crociare
l'atlantico
ma loro hanno cercato due donne invece
di tre tipi senza soldi e ma parlando
con loro il mio italiano
molto bravo ma il mio caro amico e
nicola lui parlava con con loro e loro
hanno detto sì che diamo l'opportunità e
le portiamo a brasile sarà un molto
felice abbiamo partiti partito in questa
barca a vela piccola e l'ha avuto un
momento di riflettere tutte le cose
belle che abbiamo vissuto nell'aiuto
della gente in condizionalmente e
abbiamo capito che in verità anche
avvolge il mondo sembra un po nero
sembra grigio sembra triste che in
verità la vita è pieno di bella gente e
belle cose e che se vogliamo cercare
vedere le cose belle succedano come è
successo con questa barca a vela
italiani che ci hanno preso e ho deciso
che questa esperienza di andare a
messico senza soldi volevo chiudere
questo capitolo
tornando a ruba ma volevo continuare con
superiore soldi quando siamo arrivato
arrivati a brasile e il nostro amico
italiano nicola lui ha lasciato a noi è
un po più tardi arrivato alla mia
meravigliosa donna neve non so se questo
ha la mia cara donna e con lei stato
ancora più facce di andare autostop
amber america latina e così poco a poco
stiamo
arrivato verso del nord e 10 mesi dopo
alla fine siamo arrivati e messico e
anche siamo mezzo anni più tardi che le
matrimoni e viaggio stato un successo
perché abbiamo aperti gli occhi la mente
e al cuore e ho lasciato e del
condizionamento della mia famiglia della
mia cultura e ho smesso di mangiare
prodotti animali ed event altro un
vegano
ma non solo perché amo agli animali
perchè ho scoperto che più del 50 per
cento di tutte le casse con effetto sere
provengano dell'industria delle animali
e quello e di più che tutto il traffico
della eri macchine nave e eccetera
tutto quello che si muove e quindi e
passa di ridurre il consumo e animali e
lo più forte che ognuno può fare per
ridurre l'impronta ecologica ed è fare
qualcosa per un mondo migliore dove
anche un genere generazioni del futuro
possano vivere esprimersi respirare e
vivere in armonia con la natura e in
questo momento la mia donna rimane
rimasto è incinta e quello ci ha dato
una spinta per tornare all europa e
quando siamo arrivati
ho detto che comunque siamo vivere senza
soldi dobbiamo trovare una casa un
appartamento e ci sono solo in europa
più di 12 milioni le case appartamento e
un vuote e abbiamo detto dobbiamo anche
creare più coscienza che noi dobbiamo
sempre a costruire di più ma usare più
le risorse e le case che abbiamo e alla
fine abbiamo trovato un piccolo
appartamento e che possiamo che ne
sappiamo di più è solo un tetto
certamente cibo e nel viaggio già fatto
tante esperienze ma in bellino
ha fatto il master del gangster diving
vuoi dire cercare nei bidoni quello che
la gente spreca le aziende sprecano ogni
giorno un sacco di cose e ho visto che
alla fine in ogni bidone del
supermercato c'è cos'e ogni giorno che
si può mangiare ancora che loro non
potevano o non volevano vendere e anche
sempre ha avuto sufficiente cibo per la
mia famiglia e amici abbiamo condiviso
certamente a ho deciso che volevo fare
qualcosa di più ed è fare qualcosa
legale perché in germania come la
maggior parte del paese del mondo prende
il cibo dei bidoni e proibito è illegale
mettere il cibo che si può mangiare
ancora quello è legale e quindi io
pensavo come si può fare con un concetto
che funziona e ho cominciato deve
parlare con i supermercati e un
supermercato organico mi ha dato la
possibilità di prendere cibo prima che
impiegati lo buttano via
e quello è stato il momento del
commercio del movimento fu coeli
il sistema funziona abbastanza semplice
all'inizio hai bisogno di una squadra un
paio di persone e dopo parli con un
supermercato ristorante cantina
qualsiasi altro negozio como anche
produttori agricoltori e chiedi quando
loro vogliono che noi andiamo a prendere
quello che non possano vendere più e
così a beni sempre puntuale 6 gentile
con la gente e prendi tutto quello che
loro danno quello risparmia anche soldi
soldi per i negozi perché i bidoni
costano denaro e in generale potevano
ridurre 70 per cento delle bidoni quindi
un gran risparmio anche ecologicamente
ma anche economicamente per le aziende e
oggi quattro anni più tardi
e movimento dei foo cenni attivo
praticamente in tutto germania austria e
svizzera e potevamo grazie a 10 a 9
mille persone risparmiare salvare chiude
5 milioni di chili del cibo che ha così
se vede un po di cibo delle bidoni e
potevamo così severe e condividere il
cibo e adesso severe anche un po in
tutta la gente che hanno aiutato perché
questo non stato possibile senza tutto
nell'aiuto delle volontari che sono
attivi che organizzano le nuove persone
che attivano le nuove aziende
e così grazie a tutti quanti i 2.500
negozi aziende potevamo fare veramente
un cambio ma ancora non stato
sufficiente abbiamo deciso che dobbiamo
fare qualcosa di più ed è andare davanti
ed è fare possibile questa possibilità
di offrire questo attrezzo questa
piattaforma che abbiamo creato per tutte
la gente e nel mondo ma non solo
volevano recuperare il cibo ma anche
tutte le altre cose che buttiamo via via
per esempio in germania
ogni anno se puta un milione di
tonnellate e vestiti e non solo delle
aziende non solo della gente privata ma
anche delle aziende e anche se tuttavia
i fiori i libri che non si possano
vendere in ogni altro negozio azienda
seduta ho un sacco di cose e nessuno
prende a queste cose perché
economicamente non vale la pena no
si no non renne sufficiente soldi quindi
più economico buttarlo e quindi adesso
stiamo sviluppando una nuova piattaforma
che si chiama scelsi che aiuta a tutte
le persone nel mondo
e veramente prendere quello che altri
non lo vogliano usare aziende ma anche
degente privato perché oggi in ogni casa
in europa c'è più di 10.000 cose che in
generale non lo usiamo quasi mai quindi
sia sì concerne sì possiamo creare una
piattaforma del bene comune
le cose che lo possa liberare per
esempio un libro o un zaino anche un
vecchia una vecchia camera che non lo ho
bisogno più una bici possa liberare
queste cose e invece le cose come
facebook presicce i gruppi dove se può
condividere gratis le cose le cose
iniziano a viaggiare
quindi sì io dove un libro a una persona
un'altra persona può chiedere a questa
persona il libro è così comincia a
viaggiare ogni volta abbiamo bisogno di
meno che meno cose perché abbiamo
accesso a quello che esiste e secondo me
oggi siamo svegliandoci che alla fine
quello che abbiamo bisogno noi di essere
il proprietario del tutto quello che
usiamo ma piuttosto tenere e l'accesso e
conserve se vogliamo creare una cultura
condividere una cultura di essere
patrone delle cose quindi quando tu le
usi le pratiche come se fosse la tua
camera to letto la tua macchina ed è
lasciare libero questo pensiero che
dobbiamo ogni volta tenere dei più cose
e come stavamo parlando della crisi
io credo che ogni crisi è una
possibilità personale ma anche per la
società che crescete e ogni crisi ogni
giorno abbiamo la possibilità di trovare
nostra vocazione trovare veramente
qualcosa che c'è piena che aiuta
la società anche per le prossime
generazioni perché noi siamo ospiti di
qua e si continua mo solo come i nostri
genitori e sempre di più i di più questo
pianeta dopo vivere con tanta gente
quindi dobbiamo cambiare come viviamo
qua in questo pianeta e si tutte la
gente del mondo vivano come oggi e non
ruba
abbiamo bisogno del 2 o 3 pianete quindi
noi dobbiamo aspettare che qualcun altro
cambio che c'è una nuova legge dello
stato che le aziende cambiano ma
dobbiamo vivere e cambio che vogliamo
vedere nel mondo noi stessi e ispirare
le altri e lasciarsi ispirare e le
auguro il meglio per ascoltare cuore e
trovare il vostro senso la vita da
trovare qualcosa una vocazione dove
veramente siete felice che alla fine
crearono un insieme dove tutti anni
sufficienti sufficiente da mangiare
e sufficiente tempo per tenere anche
tempi per la famiglia creare ip e di
creare insieme un mondo in pace dove
tutti sono felice grazie per
l'attenzione
[Applauso]